roll up roll up Step Right This Way
ladies and gentlemen on the other side
of these canvas doors you're about to
witness something so monstrous so
hideous so repulsive that it will turn
your stomachs and fill you with
amazement the creature you'll find in
this tent has been known to elicit all
manner of responses from well to do
folks like yourselves you may want to
laugh at it you may want to strike it
down you may even want to throw rotten
fruit at it and believe you me we are
prepared for that you will find all man
of Rotten Tomatoes eggs and other
festering foods that are begging to be
pelted for the low low price of five
cents per handful if you follow me
through these doors and gather around
this cage quietly perhaps you will see
it wait for your eyes to adjust to the
dark and hold your revulsion until you
cannot bear it anymore only then will we
get to look at the papery gray skin
sagging loose over a swollen gut Marvel
had its three drunk legs barely strong
enough to upon its own weight its
deformed trunk that hangs limp off the
front of its face and its ridiculous
ears that flap nervously when it's
afraid don't be afraid of the tusks
sticking out from its face or its cries
of pain and anguish instead hold your
tongues and wait for if you're patient
enough and perhaps with a slight beating
it may even play us a song with the
valves on its trunk then and only then
you're permitted to Pelt The Elephant
Man with whatever you see fit as you
bask in the glory of Hermann Fuller's
circus of the disquieting Rhys Freeman
didn't have much of a choice but to join
the circus at the age of 14. the cast
out son of a freed slave in New Orleans
he spent much of his early life
wandering the streets trying not to get
into any trouble in the late 1800s very
few places were interested in hiring a
young black man unless of course they
were looking to turn him back to the
life that his father had fought so hard
to escape that's why when Reese was out
fishing one afternoon and saw a big red
tent going up on the outskirts of town
he couldn't help but Wander Over much to
a surprise a group of black men were the
ones raising the Marquee they didn't
look like slaves either Reese had never
heard of a circus the closest he'd ever
come to seeing was a traveling
entertainment cart that would sometimes
pop up around town with a dancing bear
in a cage or a glass ball in a pack of
tarot cards the brightly colored tents
that went up one after another were
enough to draw a crowd even the most
well respected in New Orleans came out
for a look standing ankle deep in the
river Rhys peered over at the man who
came out to address the throng dressed
in a long tail coat with a tall Top Hat
the man stood on a box of fruit and
waved a cane dramatically in the air
good folks of new Orleans what you're
about to witness tonight has never
before been seen this side of the
Mississippi wonders and amazement Galore
spectacle in entry mystery and Mayhem
and just a touch of the impossible I go
by the name of Herman Fuller the most
talented and notorious circus master in
the entire United States the dazzling
array of shows that I've brought before
you is not for the faint of heart or the
week of constitution your stomachs will
be turned and your minds may be altered
but it promises to be a night that you
will never forget Rhys wasn't much
interested in any of what he had just
said this kind of Two Penny show was
reserved for the folks who had the money
to throw around on needless things like
smiling and having a nice evening what
Rhys was far more interested in were the
groups of men working behind the scenes
pulling various carts and setting up all
of the Stalls a lot of them didn't look
much older than him a grin spray bread
across his face
scp-4409 insisted on being interviewed
in the dark with all the lights in the
interview chamber Switched Off Dr Simon
Crossley entered the room and sat down
across from the Elephant Man even in the
dim light though he was able to still
make out part of the man's features the
ivory tusks the hanging nose and the
nervously twitching ears the man had
been picked up in St Louis where local
police had found him panhandling in the
streets while he certainly seemed
harmless enough it was important for the
foundation to take him in just to be
sure sitting in the dark interview room
Reese Freeman was apprehensive at first
about telling his side of the story a
life of being mocked spat on and chased
out of towns had left him with a real
distrust of other people that was
probably made worse by his apprehension
at being put in another cage within the
foundation he told Dr Crossley that he
was born as normal as could be that his
current ghastly Affliction was was
something done to him quite some time
ago but as much as it pained him to
recollect it was a tale that he knew
he'd probably have to tell Dr Crossley
replied that he was all ears it took Dr
Crossley a few seconds to realize his
faux pas
scp-4409 glared at him before continuing
to explain how he was made the way he
was Reese Freeman had managed to land a
job with the circus surprisingly easily
despite having no previous experience
and no references to back him up Hermann
Fuller took a shine to him it was menial
work and not many folks were up to doing
it but since Rhys had never had a job
before he didn't know any better he
started out at the bottom of the ladder
scraping out feces washing down old
cages and carrying heavy crates the one
scrawny 14 year old boy quickly turned
into a stocky 17 year old with broad
shoulders and strong legs they would
travel from town to town across most of
the United States stopping off in major
cities for weeks at a time to bring in
as much money as possible before moving
on rest didn't save much that money but
he didn't mind the fact that he got two
meals a day and something to do with
himself was enough in fact he kind of
enjoyed sleeping on top of the carts as
the horses pulled them across the dusty
American roads the one thing that always
seemed to affect him though was that he
was never allowed to actually see inside
the tents he would see folks come and go
through the canvas doors week after week
but was never allowed so much as a peak
inside himself the older guys were
responsible for throwing the canvas
sheets over the cages which would remain
that way as they traveled not having
seen much of the world at that point
Reese didn't have much of an idea of
what could be in those cages perhaps
some kind of animal from a foreign
country something from Africa or Asia
they made all kinds of noise Reese said
that most of them sounded like humans
but then they'd go and make strange
animal sounds that no human mouth could
ever produce one night his curiosity
City got the better of him hanging back
before the crowds got into the tent he
sidestepped over to the entrance making
sure that no one saw him and took a peek
through the doorway it was dark inside
too dark to make out much of what was
happening the crowd of people was
standing between him and the cage all
jostling and leaning this way and that
trying to make out whatever it was that
was inside a screeching sound filled the
air making the whole crowd and Reese
outside jump right standing on his
tiptoes he tried his best to see what
was moving around in that cage it seemed
to be moving around like a person
lurching this way and that but the
sounds coming from it sounded more like
a bird and sure enough after a moment a
huge pair of disproportionately ugly
Wings stretched out from either side of
the creature flapping and sending a rush
of air through the tents so powerful
that it blew the flap wide open in front
of him just as Herman Fuller turned
around to see him standing there Rhys
bolted and hid behind one of the carts
he was going to be in trouble for this
he was sure of it it was one of Fuller's
only rules of the circus and he had just
gone and broken it he was in the hottest
water imaginable but as nighttime fell
and the drags of the spectators wandered
out of the tent Fuller seemed to be in
too bad a mood at all watching him from
a distance Rhys got the impression that
he might not actually be in as much
trouble as he thought Fuller caught his
eye and came over Kane twirling and Top
Hat sitting jauntily atop his head Rhys
got off on the wrong foot apologizing
right away for spying into the tent the
circus Master just laughed it off and
slapped him on the back Reese my boy
don't worry about it I've got much
bigger plans for you much much bigger
that night as Rhys lay in bed yet a
terrible dream about what he had seen in
the tent that day circus of the
disquieting was certainly an apt title
for this place the image of that strange
shadowy bird person in the cage haunted
his nightmares until suddenly two pairs
of strong hands gripped him and ripped
him out of his sleep he knew better than
to fight back this was surely going to
be his comeuppance for breaking Fuller's
rules earlier they dragged him into the
main event where there was an oil lamp
in the middle Illuminating what looked
like a heavy wooden operating table his
wrists and ankles were strapped in and
then the two men left him alone he had
half a mind to scream but with all the
Caged up creatures from the circus
around him he doubted anyone would pay
him much mind it was almost an hour
before Hermann Fuller walked into the
tent by this point Reese expected him to
be walking in with surgical equipment
gloves maybe even a saw but the man had
nothing in his bare hands Hermann Fuller
asked him if he ever heard of Joseph
Merrick Reese didn't answer of course
he'd heard of the Elephant Man the whole
world had been talking about Joseph
Merrick for months a man born so
hideously deformed that people had
compared him to an elephant though the
resemblance wasn't that convincing this
sentiment was clearly shared by Fuller
who placed one hand on either side of
Reese's face and began to softly massage
his cheeks explaining how disappointed
he was was that Merrick didn't actually
look all that much like an elephant
Reese's cheeks started to hurt as the
man massaged him almost as if he was
stretching and pulling at his face
finding loose skin the boy asked Fuller
what he was doing the circus Master just
smiled at him and explained that it was
an old technique handed down in his
family a gift he called it he started
touching Reese's nose gently pulling at
it with more and more pressure much to
Reese's surprise he felt his nose
elongating growing longer and longer in
the man's hand he tried to Twitch his
face and was starting to find that his
new nose twitched along with it the
longer it grew the more painful it felt
the skin and flesh from his head being
ripped and pulled into a new shape at
several points Rhys felt ready to pass
out from the agony but the circus Master
kept talking to him kept him awake
through the whole ordeal as he molded
the boy's face like clay into the shape
of an elephant lying on the bench
panting Rhys could see his trunk from
between his two eyes it was a nightmare
that was all it was but then Fuller
reached under the workbench and lifted
out a small hand drill one by one he
punched holes into the top of Reese's
trunk installing little valves like a
trumpet as he went standing back to
admire his handiwork he told Rhys that
he would be his new favorite attraction
my boy I have made you into a star the
tusks did not come straight away over
the course of several months they slowly
and painfully emerged from his deformed
jaw his elephantine legs were also not
part of his initial transformation but
instead came as a result of health
issues he developed while being trapped
in a cage for several decades crowds of
people would come and go flocking to see
the Elephant Man having spent the first
part of his life constantly hungry Reese
was now being overfed every day hands
would come to his cage and force him to
eat Rich fatty foods denying him any
possibility of exercise the broad
shoulders and strong legs that he had
developed while working at the circus
melted away under layers and layers of
fat his skin went gray and papery
folding and wrinkling in on itself by
the are from Fuller's magic or just from
a lack of sunlight whatever it was with
every passing day Rhys Freeman steadily
became more and more hideous
scp-4409 was stuck in the circus for
much of his life eventually Hermann
Fuller moved on and is currently being
hunted by the SCP Foundation when he did
scp-4409 was able to bargain for its
freedom from the circus wandering from
City to City never sticking around for
very long
scp-4409 begged for change at the side
of the road some people would feel
sympathy While most would feel horror at
its disfigurement from its years trapped
in a cage
scp-4409 has developed severe health
issues including gout severe obesity and
metabolic syndrome while in Foundation
custody it is fed a special diet to
counteract these conditions as of yet
the foundation has no way of reversing
what was done to Rhys Freeman in the
tent in the 1800s as Reese poses no
threat to the foundation
is allowed to live with relative Freedom
or at least as much Freedom as a
contained SCP can earn his health
condition severely limits his Mobility
around site-66 a low security
residential containment area unable to
walk even moderate distances
scp-4409 heavily relies on the use of a
cane and a heavy duty Walker capable of
supporting up to 140 kilograms
researchers listen intently at his door
waiting to hear if he's ever going to
play a sad song on his trumpet but no
sound ever emerges except for his heavy
breathing and spluttering coughs it
appears that having spent decades locked
in a small cage a sedentary life is all
he knows now with every opportunity to
exercise read books and take up new
hobbies
scp-4409 appears unable to engage with
anything other than sitting and staring
at the same spot on the wall every day
if an animal has spent its whole life
living in a zoo and finds in its old age
that one of the wall has fallen down
what use has it in taking a step outside
now check out scp-082 fernan the
cannibal and scp-5031 yet another murder
monster